The needle retaining bar also known as
a sponge bar or sponge presser bar on
knitting machines holds the needles
in place for proper Stitch formation.
Most metal bed machines
have this retaining bar.
A deteriorated or flattened sponge bar
is the cause of many problems that new
Knitters experience.
Replacing the sponge bar is simple
and should be done regularly.
Now this photo is an exaggeration.
But if your needles are sitting up
and they're not tight against the bed.
It's time to replace your sponge bar.
They are available online from many
retailers and they're relatively
inexpensive.
Many Knitters will remove their sponge bar
from the machine when they're not knitting
for long periods of time.
Some Knitters will rotate sponge bars
using one and let the other rest.
This may prolong the life of the bar.
But normal deterioration will flatten the
sponge and require replacing at some point
a flat and sponge Bart can cause
many many issues in your knitting.
It can cause broken or bent needles.
Damage to your carriage.
Skip stitches in patterning.
Drop stitches and general
knitting problems.
To replace your sponge bar first
remove the carriage from the machine.
Be sure that all the needles are pushed
back into A or non-working position.
Don't remove the sponge bar when the
needles are fully out or in holding
position.
Start by using a screwdriver or a sturdy
tool of some sort to push the end of that
bar to the inside of the Machine.
Push far enough so that you can
take hold of it at the other end.
Pull the bar firmly
and start to remove it.
Now notice how the bar is positioned
in the machine before removing.
It completely.
Most commonly this sponge is
face down against the needles.
Also notice as you're pulling it out how
the needles pop-up away from the bed.
To replace the bar user needle Pusher to
hold the needles down and replace the bar
on top of them.
Work your way slowly across the bed
until the bar is completely inserted.
Our knitting machines don't take a lot
of Maintenance that this is one thing you
can't ignore.
Change your sponge bar.